now for the main event uh again uh the
resolution readed the making of national
internet policy was hindered rather than
helped by the fed by the July 4th
Federal Court ruling that restricted the
Biden administration's Communications
with social media platforms here for the
affirmative Kate clonic Kate please come
to the
stage speaking for the negative uh Jay
uh yeah Jay bachara Jay please come to
the
stage uh Grant please close the voting K
Professor Kate kenck you have 17 and a
half minutes to defend the resolution
take it away
Kate thank you so much for that um
having me here today it's an honor to be
in invited to debate Dr badara on this
resolution and to take the side of the
affirmative um I want to begin my
remarks today by first setting the
factual stage for the case that we're
discussing and the ruling that prompted
this debate Missouri V Biden which came
out on July 4th of this year um I will
argue that in its over Brad opinion this
case first harms National internet
policy by misunderstanding the
pluralistic system of governance not
government that have developed to help
private social media companies maximize
freedom of expression while also
balancing counterveiling concerns for
Public Safety and public health second I
will argue that the courts are not the
correct institutional Avenue to set what
is effectively not just National but
Global governance on Online private
speech uh platforms and their policies
and thus both the substance of this
opinion and the institution that
generated it have hindered the creation
of national inter internet policy and in
doing so ultimately jeopardized freedom
of expression with that overview let me
just start with a brief procedural
history of this case the Missouri V
Biden ruling was a 155 page opinion on a
preliminary injunction issued by Judge
Terry dowy a federal trial court judge
in the US District Court for the Western
District of
Louisiana the case was brought by two
Republican state attorney generals uh
Attorneys General in Missouri and
Louisiana
and five private individuals including
my opponent here today uh the Pres the
plaintiffs alleged that the defendants
President Biden M and various members of
his administration through public
pressure campaigns private meetings and
other forms of direct communication
around disinformation misinformation and
malformation colluded with and or
coerced social media platforms to
suppress disfavored speakers viewpoints
and content on social media platforms
that that suppression constituted
government action and therefore was a
violation of the First Amendment right
to free
speech specifically the facts in the
case include episodes in which members
of the Biden Administration sent
frenetic uh sometimes even profanity
laced messages to employees of social
media companies asking or even demanding
that the platforms remove doubtful
claims about co9 and the 2020
election it's important to note that I
actually agree with judge Dy that the
apparent pressure that the Biden
Administration places on platforms is
certainly questionable these incidents
seem like they could potentially be
classic examples of what political
scientists call Job owning the
government's use of public appeals or
private channels to induce change or
compliance from
businesses but the degree to which these
demands are heated or coercive is still
very much uncertain it certainly was
uncertain in a preliminary injunction
motion and in issuing an over over rod
preliminary injunction the ruling not
only sets back the development of
national internet policy it harms
freedom of expression and the creation
of well-managed and governed Pro private
online speech
environments so let me explain with an
example of where the lack of clarity
around job owning and an overreaction to
it might play out under existing First
Amendment Doctrine most notably bantom
books it is clear from it is far from
Clear where the line should be drawn
between government participation in
useful conversations on public policy
and when that tips into State ordered
coercion this is particularly true in
the new world of private individual
speech organized distributed and hosted
by private
platforms for example hypothetically the
White House emailing the head of the
trust and safety in Twitter and saying
if you don't take down pro-anorexia
content responding by we will like we
will respond by issuing an executive
order against you and then Twitter
accordingly responds to the process to
ban All Pro anorexia content that would
be a clear instance of job owning and an
unconstitutional government censorship
but it is not clear what might happen if
Twitter in seeking to be more
accountable to its users and more
responsive to their concerns over Teen
Mental Health and eating disorders asks
the CDC to be among a set of
stakeholders that meets with Twitter's
public policy team in order to determine
bre best practices on pro-anorexia
content this latter example
multistakeholderism and expert input
which might sometimes include parts of
government is how much of the internet
policy on major online speech platforms
is currently being set and it's
something those of us who work in online
speech and who care about freedom of
expression have long thought for
accountability of these major online
speech platforms to its users both
Direct IR ly and indirectly because it
is something that the public has long
demanded and it's something that is best
not left to the hands of government
specifically for First Amendment reasons
and so the power and influence of big
speech platforms has undoubtedly
increased over time and it's
fundamentally altered the freedom of
expression and let me explain a little
bit by backing up and saying what I mean
by
that this new model for free expression
is what Yale law professor Jack Bulan
calls the Free Speech triangle for most
of modern history the story of speech
governance concerns just two parties
citizens and the state the everpresent
danger of this dietic model is that the
mass of power the boot of the state is
on the neck of citizens in their defense
citizens have things like voting speech
protest uh Democratic mechanisms and
they're constitutionally guaranteed in
the United States with Provisions like
the First Amendment to help resist
government censorship but there's still
rying for much of their speech on
Gatekeepers Publishers and the press to
amplify their message and reach a large
audience that is something that we also
enshrine in the First Amendment their
own right to do
that this might have been the struggle
forever but the internet changed this
dynamic in huge Ways by allowing
individual citizens to Route Around the
potential or actual C censorship put in
place by States and also to amplify
their message directly and step out of
the role of
Gatekeepers
oh I'm being I'm
like
[Laughter]
okay I want those minutes put back on
the clock yeah I
know now there were only anyways this
might have been the struggle forever but
the internet changed the dynamic by both
allowing individual citizens to Route
around any censorship put in place by
the States but to amplify their message
directly we all kind of know this techno
utopianism that the internet brought us
now there were three players not just
governments and citizens but online
speech platforms and of course we have
seen that the internet and private
speech platforms while opening
incredible new avenues of access to
information self-expression democracy
has also led to an increase in because
these are fairly these are neutral
platforms harassment defamation
pornography tide pod challenges B
bullying more sharing of child sexual
abuse material spam fraud terrorism
recruitment the list goes
on contrary to those that call for a
so-called absolute Free Speech
environment either design dis discussion
or democracy First Amendment theory has
always allowed and in fact required
rules and architecture in order to
preserve a functioning speech
environment be that time place manner
restrictions or on protests or banss on
megaphones and Parks ideal environments
for free expression require rules
accountability and Norms to function
properly but what those rules should be
and who should set them in these new
speech environments online is a near
impossible question with the powers were
just governments and citizens and it is
even more difficult to discern in the
context of online speech platforms which
themselves have their own First
Amendment right to seek guidance on what
speech they decide to host on their
platforms and which includes if they so
choose deciding to tether their private
speech policies to input received from
the
government so let's bring this back to
the case at hand for many of them for
many of the misinformation policies
around covid and the pandemic the
platform's decision to ask the CDC for
guidance was the choice of the platform
during a time of much confusion in the
midst a pandemic private social media
platforms independently created and
enforced speech policies and content
moderation policies around covid-19 and
tried to inform these decisions during a
very uninformed period through guidance
from government agencies like the CDC
this was not only their right under the
First Amendment it is unclear why that
it was exactly a pragmatically poor
decision what other authorities should
speech platforms reach out to in order
to moderate and curate their speech
policies in the midst of a global Public
Health
crisis but D's ruling on July 4th which
sided with the plaintiffs and issued a
prelim AR injunction was frighteningly
over Brad seemed to prevent anyone in
the Biden Administration from having any
kind of communication with online
platforms about matters related to
speech it seemed that platforms and
governments were so constricted under
this preliminary injunction that it was
unclear uh if there platforms would
speak at all to any government agency or
official for any reason about things
that were posted online this includes
preparing governments for election
interference National Security issues
there were some car that seemed like
they might actually be themselves uh go
against First Amendment doctrine that we
had specifically said the government is
not allowed to reach out to criminal
issues and other types of um National
Security issues other policy issues that
the public was clamoring for improvement
on from Teen Mental Health and suicide
to eating disorders or life-threatening
social media challenges all of that were
even less likely to have justification
for export agency import on
reform but as I wrote in an oped at the
time ruling was more than the ruling was
more than a muddled set of instructions
for communication between government and
pl Tech platform which is an urgent
issue for those concerned with
misinformation as we approach the 2024
presidential election it is also a
bellweather of disconcerting new
political tactic one that use state and
local authorities along with Federal
forum and judge shopping to make
National internet
policy after years of failed attempts by
Congress to regulate major social social
media platforms not clear whether the
regulation would have um been upheld
under the First Amendment but regulation
that for nearly a decade Americans of
all political Stripes have been saying
that they want State authorities are
rushing in to capitalize on an unmet
political demand other examples includes
laws passed in Florida and Texas that
prohibit larger social media platforms
from removing posts based on the
opinions they express and the ban on Tik
Tock that Montana has passed I think
Virginia has recently passed a number of
bills there's Utah going local has
strategic if sometimes unethical
advantages it is no accident that the
case this case arose in Louisiana in
this case judge dowy a Donald Trump
appointee was at the time the only judge
who heard cases filed in the Monroe
division of the Western District of the
state by choosing their venue the
plaintiffs in effect got to choose their
judge and similarly it is no accident
that the same Monroe Division and with
judge dowy presiding again is also the
venue for a pending civil suit that
hosts a PR a host of private actors
Loosely connected to the case against
the Biden administration of conspiracy
to engage in Mass surveillance and
censorship appeals in both cases will be
heard and then have been heard by the US
court of appeals for the fifth circuit
which has been sympathetic to State
attempts to regulate big
Tech but issues of Miss and
disinformation and public health are
issues of Public Safety and public
concern and they are also issues that
the public demands be add added by the
Pate private platforms and that's why
it's a shame that factionalized state
politics and Forum Shopping is going to
possibly determine the
resolution so what would be a better
alternative how do you regulate a public
right like freedom of expression when
that right is intermediated by private
companies what role if any can or should
the government
play while more guidance from the courts
would be welcome in where to draw the
line for the purposes of job Waring and
defining coercion National preliminary
injunctions from Forum shop judges are
not the right way in the long term to
solve the much thornier public private
pluralism questions that continue to
make governance of online speech
platform the center of not just National
interest but Global
concern internet speech has specific
features in both technical design and
economic feasibility and normative
outcome that make it particularly hard
to make rules for and in terms of legal
rights they demand a delicate balance
preserving their own First Amendment
rights and the First Amendment rights of
their users large online speech
platforms connect the world and the
world's information and conversations
into soal town squares or even front
room parlors operating transnationally
connecting people and ideas largely
irrespective of national or political
boundaries and this is where the problem
gets difficult despite these online
intermediaries all being private
entities we see them as governing a
fundamental human right a public right
of freedom of expression and that is
something that demands governance
but not government in order to preserve
organize curate and
encourage developing a national indeed
global internet policy that does that
requires a more sophisticated and
pluralistic model than you will ever get
from one judge in Louisiana thank you I
look forward to the rest of the
debate thank you Kate sorry that my
stupid machine acted up uh I take it you
got compensated uh uh Jay uh for the
negative 17 and a half minutes take it
away
Jay thanks everybody so when I was 19 I
became an American citizen it was one of
the happiest days of my life uh the
immigration officer gave me a Civics
test uh including a question about the
First Amendment it was an easy test
because I knew it by heart right the
American Civic religion is Free Speech
to its has free speech at its at the
core of its liturgy I I never imagined
there would come a time when the
American government would think that
violating this right would be just the
normal thing to do or that I personally
would become the target of it
unfortunately that is that did become
true during the pandemic both things my
family immigrated from India when I was
four but my parents would often talk
about Indian politics they were the
children of violent partition of India
and Pakistan and in Bangladesh both my
parents had grown up in poverty my mom
and a Kolkata slum uh they knew
firsthand how authoritarian governments
hurt the poor I remember in
1975 uh a high court found that then
Indian Prime Minister indur Gandhi had
interfered unlawfully in an election the
ruling disqualified her from from
holding office in response she declared
a state of emergency suspended Indian
democracy censored the opposition uh the
press and government critics and threw
her political opponents in jail I
remember the shock of these events and
our fam's Collective relief that we were
in the United States where such events
could never
happen unfortunately during the pandemic
the American government violated my own
free speech rights and those of my
scientist colleagues for the crime of
questioning government policy regarding
covid my parents had taught me that the
people here could criticize the
government even over matters of life and
death without worry of censorship
because of the American commitment to
free speech but over the past four years
I have been robbed of that illusion
American government officials working in
concert with big tech companies coercing
them pushing them forcing them often
threatening them have attacked and
suppressed me and my colleagues for
criticizing official pandemic
policies criticism that's proven preent
and had it been heed would have resulted
in much fewer harms to American school
children to the American poor and to the
American working class and would have
resulted in better covid
outcomes in in the mid 15th century the
invention of the Gutenberg Press vastly
decreased the cost of access to ideas
governments and ecclesiastical
authorities reacted to the challenge uh
posed by the uncontrolled spread of
these ideas by pointing the danger of
books and pamphlets spreading dissent
heresy and Rebellion arguing that uh
unregulated ideas like the heliocentric
universe or that the king is a tyrant uh
would harm a public vulnerable to
dangerous ideas both secular authorities
and the church brutally censored the
Press on pain of excommunication or
death the invention of the internet and
social media poses a challenge to
Authority similar to the Gutenberg Press
as the printing press did those
Technologies sharply decreased the cost
for regular people to reach vast
audiences with their ideas and with no
filter imposed by media companies or
governments they empowered people to
organize enormous social political
movements like the Arab Spring and
Occupy Wall Street in 2009 brexit in
2015 and the upset election of Donald
Trump in 2016 whatever one's opinions of
those those events these populist
movements would have been unimaginable
to organize without activists using
social media to reach Mass audiences in
response to the evident influence the
social media give to the masses
authorities today did exactly what those
ecclesiastical and government
authorities did during the invention of
the Gutenberg Press they censored people
now on social media whose ideas posed a
threat to those polic those in policy
those those people in power Western
governments have developed a vast
censorship apparatus designed to block
offending ideas and speech on social
media and to defame political opponents
as dangerous Heretics perhaps working
under the undue influence of foreign
actors spreading Mis dis and Mal
information to the unsuspecting masses
even in the US which supposed to have a
functioning First
Amendment the federal judge in the
Missouri versus Biden case found that
the B administration had constructed an
orwellian Ministry of Truth his words
not mine devoted to censoring Americans
the federal uh appeals judges which
heard the case three three of them
signed on to that phrasing calling it
essentially a a censorship industrial
complex in the United States imposed by
the government itself on social media
and on users on regular
Americans a silicon wall of censorship
is coming down all around the onfree
world laws such as the eu's digital
Service Act the UK's Online safety Bill
Canada's Bill C11 an Australian Bill and
draft to combat misinformation
disinformation all provide Western
governments the power arbitrary sensor
which uh that they've used to suppress
the speech of opposition political
parties they've used to suppress
scientific ideas that that contradict
government edicts and even religious
worship the analogy with the Gutenberg
Press goes further except in the Modern
Age government scientific bureaucracies
have replaced the medieval Church in
their power to excommunicate Heretics
from public Life Tony fouchy the former
head of the National Institute of
allergy infect disease exemplifies as
Hubris in an interview with a cable TV
host in 2021 he put forward a modern
version of papal infallibility he said
if you are trying to get me as a public
health official and a scientist you're
really attacking not only Dr Tony fouchy
you're attacking
science proponents of these censorship
Powers inevitably cite the harm that
people come from people being exposed to
untruths or even foreign propaganda they
make the wrong medical decisions they
lose trust in in social institutions or
vote for the wrong people hearing this
misinformation they argue underlying
this worry is the dubious and dangerous
proposition that people are too naive
and stupid to distinguish true from
false at scale we've come a long way
from the 1990s when liberal governments
trusted the wisdom of crowds to a
situation where the elites fear and
distrust the public they are nominally
govern in this new era of censorship 19
in in 19th century liberal philosopher
John Stuart Mills logic that the public
correction of incorrect ideas improves
knowledge and wisdom of the public is
now replaced with the Towering knowledge
of gurus like Tony Fouch
the problem is that government and the
entities are bad at identifying
misinformation and they have a
propensity to censor people and ideas
that are critical of government policy
whether or not those criticisms of their
policies are correct take for instance
the censorship covid science on masks
lockdowns immunity vaccines the
government censored online scientific
discussions to protect a narrative aimed
at manipulating The public's Behavior
often at the expense of the truth and if
you read the discovery in the Missouri
versus Biden case you'll see this
Reckless disregard for scient the truth
of scientific propositions in the
censorship demands all that mattered was
that critics were criticizing government
policy though scientists and people
vehemently disagreed about the wisdom of
lockdowns school closures vaccine
mandates and discrimination masks and so
much else there's near Universal
agreement that what we did absolutely
failed and what I want to tell you is
that the primary reason that the United
States failed so badly to manage covid
was that the government itself was a
primary source of
misinformation it's not it's uh the
pandemic response brought tremendous
collateral harm there's now broad
agreement for instance there a school
closures in some some states running for
almost a year and a half my own kids
stayed out of school or locked out of
school houses for almost a year and a
half have set kids behind in ways that
would lead them to worse outcomes at
adults including shorter poorer lives we
we have accelerated inequality into the
Next Generation with our pandemic
policies and at the time the government
was criticized about it but worked very
hard to sense of critics one uh the the
losses are unequally distributed with
poor and minority kids suffering the
worst learning losses worldwide millions
of kids never returned when schools
finally
opened maybe the most perplexing sin of
Public Health establishment was it
abandoned an essential commitment to
science for instance why did Public
Health authorities ignore clear
scientific data that covid infection
acquired immunity is as strong as or
stronger than vaccine acquired immunity
on the contrary the government censored
scientists ordered social media
companies to censor scientists like
Harvard University epidemiologist Martin
korf who pointed to Scientific evidence
in peer-reviewed public published papers
of this truth of that Co acquired
immunity was actually quite strong
vaccine mandates forced many Frontline
um vaccine mandates forced many
Frontline uh workers uh Heroes who cont
contracted Co early in the pandemic
while doing essential work to choose
between their careers and a vaccine that
provides less protection for the for the
people who were already recovered from
covid um than they already had than than
than it does for the people who are Co
naive University presidents forced young
male college students including those
with excellent immunity from a prior Co
infection to accept an elevated risk of
myocarditis again documented in the
peer-reviewed literature
as a price for college education and
critics of those policies online were
censored at the order of the Biden
Administration many faced with these
anti-scientific choices will never again
trust Public Health authorities even on
vital topics such as the necessity of
traditional childhood
vaccines Public Health bureaucrats and
government officials operate more like
dictators than scientists during the
pandemic sealing themselves off from
credible outside criticism consider for
instance the treatment of scientific
dissidents out outside the government
who dared to contradict Public Health
Dogma in the early days of the P
pandemic High Public Health bureaucrats
organized a cover up of the hypothesis
that covid emerged as a result of a
laboratory leak calling scientists who
propose the idea conspiracy theorists
only recently have official bodies
started to admit the hypothesis as
plausible and very likely true and
certainly not a
conspiracy where do the scientists whose
careers were destroyed by uh advancing
the idea the correct idea
go to get the reputations back the the
scientific bureaucrats use the power of
government to tell social media
companies that those scientists that
were saying absolute absolutely true
facts trying to start a conversation
that the government needed to have were
conspiracy theorists uh when Martin
kulor of Harvard University senetra
Gupta of Oxford University and I were uh
from Stanford proposed a focused
protection alternative to the lockdowns
called the Great barington declaration
in October 2020
then NIH director Francis Collins
labeled us Fringe epidemiologist which I
have on a business card if I I don't
know if I brought it with me
um they they then
engaged thank you
[Applause]
guys tens of thousands of doctors signed
this Fringe proposition uh and but the
government engaged in a media
takedown organized by Francis Collins
and Tony fouchy
under the banner of combating
misinformation they use their power to
collaborate with social medias to
control the public conversation about
the great bankton declaration in March
2021 Dr Scott Atlas Dr kerf Dr G and I
participated in a two-hour round table
with the sitting governor of Florida
Governor Ronda santis during the
discussion the participants including me
uh were asked about the efficacy of
child masing and I can tell you to this
day there's not one single randomized
study even conducted on the efficacy of
child masking much less one showing that
it's necessary to protect the public
from
Co I told the governor that and in
response YouTube took down the video of
me telling the sitting governor of a of
a state that there was a uh that that
that there was no such evidence um when
Elon uh the the the the U when Elon mus
Twitter he opened the doors of the
company to Independent journalists like
Barry Weiss when she looked at the
Twitter database she found that Twitter
had placed me on a transends black list
a word that I thought we'd put to put to
sleep in the United States in the
1950s um and when I went to Twitter
headquarters and I looked at the Twitter
database it turns out that I was placed
on that Blacklist on August 2021 the day
I joined Twitter for the crime of
posting a link to the great bton
declaration the impetus behind my being
placed on The Blacklist wasn't voluntary
Behavior by Twitter it was a direct
request by government offal officials to
censor me and this my speech so that my
speech only reached a narrow group of
people and not the public at
large the pattern repeated itself
throughout the pandemic with scientific
bureaucrats abusing their authority to
create an illusion of scientific
consensus in favor of their destructive
ideas where none existed the censorship
of government scientific discussion
permitted a policy environment where
clear scientific truths were muddled and
as a result destructive and ineffective
policies persisted much longer that on
the otherwise would have and what I'm
will tell you is that had there been an
honest and open scientific debate
without the government's use of its
power to censor we would have won the
fight over school closures schools would
have opened much earlier just as they
did in much of
Europe uh according to the court
documents found in the Missouri versus
Biden case where I am a plaintiff the
Biden Administration insisted on
censoring and de boosting content that
accurately pointed out the rapidly
waning eff of the code vaccine against
infection which they used to justify
executive orders imposing vaccine
mandates the VA the Biden White House
pressured Facebook to censor vaccine
discussions you such as groups of
vaccine injured patients who were
talking with each other trying to get
themselves comfort and figure out ways
to manage the myocarditis that their
young Sons and Daughters had
had Facebook responded that these po
these groups did not violate their
Community standards and yet the Biden
Administration insisted they get taken
down in response to harsh Communications
on the Biden Administration wasn't
simply job owning Facebook limited the
reach of these groups censored them the
evidentiary record in the case in the
Missouri for Biden Cas who includes an
eight-hour deposition of Tony fouchy
telling the court that he does not
recall answers to basic scientific and
factual questions 180 times almost is
shocking and and reading in full the
irony is that the government itself was
the primary source of misinformation as
i' as I've said so how did the
government accomplish this feat of
censorship Des despite the the
protections of free speech they did it
in two steps first they laundered the
development of a particular agenda for
censorship lists of who and what to
censor through government funded third
parties that are themselves not
prohibited from such activities in the
guise of funding research government
agencies like uh funded NOS like the
Stanford internet Observatory or welli
in names of projects like the verality
project or Center for countering digital
hate to create a Target list for
censorship uh the organizations receive
then tips from public and government
stakeholders essentially laundering the
government request to take down misin
take down information to construct their
hit list and then selling those to the
uh to the the social media companies as
if they were not government uh whereas
in fact it was the government asking for
the censorship second with government
back uh backing these private entities
linked to prominent universities like
Stanford worked with corporate teams and
social media companies trust and safety
decisions divisions to pressure social
media companies to censor offending
speech often using AI algorithms to
identify the speech marked for
censorship at scale governments are
directly involved in this step meeting
regularly with social media companies to
reinforce the censorship demands telling
them that if you do not comply then we
will the nasty things will happen to
your company one judge in the case
reading the evidentiary record not CH
Terry dowy made made an analogy to to
alone going to business saying well
that's a nice business you have there it
would be terrible if something were to
happen to
it um ironically given my opponent's
contention the government itself was
harmed by the censorship efforts in
April of 2021 the CDC issued a warning
about the J&J vaccine based on a signal
detected that was C causing clotting
events and strokes in women it paused
the distribution of the vaccine the
government then was tagged as an antia
group for sharing what the CDC
wrote
the as things stand the situation in
free speech is dire in the western world
world and the Missouri versus Biden case
is our best current defense against it
thank
you Kate Kate you get an extra 15
seconds for your rebuttal uh seven and a
half minutes plus 15 seconds for
you I just um I mean the the prompt here
was essentially that there was that this
case was um that this case and in
particular this decision was not um a
move forward for National internet
policy and I stand by that for one the
um my opponent brings up the fact that
the government did all of the censorship
but I would point out that the
government that he ended up um launching
his his suit against and that is being
targeted in this the Biden
Administration that for most of what he
is talking about in the period in time
was the Trump Administration it was from
2019 to 2020 um the the action that he
claims happened on behalf of the
government was actually the Trump
Administration government in October of
2020 is the alleged time in which Google
deboosted the search results for the
great barington declaration in October
of 2020 Trump was President um there is
um a number of points here that are just
like the timelines just don't match up
and I there is no level in which the um
the uh great barington Declaration was
while D trended on Twitter was censored
or outright banned in any capacity
except for this one YouTube video um in
March 18th of 2021 um that was taken off
of
YouTube the the other thing that I kind
of just want to bring up here is to
remind ourselves not to be uh that when
we're talking about global and National
internet policy that when we're talking
about National internet policy it is
really important not not I believe not
to tip into um overstatement about what
is actually being censored and when we
make comparisons to ideas of
authoritarian dictatorships and being
Gandhi being thrown in jail for um for
stepping out against things there was no
one thrown in jail um in in the United
States of America as far as I know for
and not you um you were not even thrown
in Twitter jail there was uh the your
account was remained sus uh remained up
the entire time that you were on Twitter
the uh your account has 400,000
followers which if they're voting in
this debate I am almost certainly going
to lose uh like people still saw your
posts and the idea that you were
blacklisted on Twitter twins merely
means that this little tiny like thing
on the side of Twitter decides not to
surface your posts there is no right for
to you have no right either through like
Twitter's own decision Facebook's own
decision any of these private platforms
decision to access that they can decide
how they want to curate their platform
that is as legitimate a First Amendment
value as yours and the idea that you
were that you were blacklisted from a
trend while still being allowed to to
speak on your platform to your four and
to build a following of 400,000 people
for free on these platforms is I think a
a pretty remarkable statement to the to
the absolute reach that your speech had
and the idea that you were anything but
censored so from a very legal
perspective here I would I would
challenge your standing I would
challenge your standing that you have uh
like you have standing against this
particular Administration versus the
other Administration some of the facts
that you have said this idea that there
is there were a lot of um kind of
glossed statements this near unal veral
agreement now that there would have been
a better income of covid had there not
been lockdowns I have not seen evidence
of that no more than I you claim to have
seen evidence of any type of scientific
study on the effectiveness of masks or
the effectiveness of vaccines and so I
just kind of want to um go back to the
idea that just because well I am sorry
that you have felt that there is this
campaign against you and your ideas I do
not think that that rises to this level
in which we decide that we're going to
RIT large change National and because
the United States is the the the
manufacturer of these Global Internet
speech platforms um that we're going to
change global internet policy because
you're big mad at fouchy is kind of the
idea that there is that this is like a
ridiculous kind of notion and really I
think takes uh a real step backwards in
the promise that we have for a
functioning and very uh very
effective uh form of governance and a
the reach of a new platform and a new
series of uh of technologies that are
wonderful for freedom of expression and
that overall have led to an increase in
science an increase in in um education
an increase in voice and freedom of
expression um and I I just I will leave
it
there seven and a half minutes for you
uh
Jay so a few points so so first I wanted
to respond to the some of the things
that Kate said during the uh her opening
statements uh she she mentioned
repeatedly that this is an a matter of
of good governance but we want to make
sure that for instance that uh National
Security is not violated on the internet
that your secrets are not violated she
didn't mention child porn but I would I
would agree with that we want to make
sure child porn is not put on the
internet that there that there are
criminal violent threats not put on the
internet I want to make clear that that
the judge in the the July 4th ruling
explicitly had exceptions allowing the
government to talk with and tell the the
social media companies explicitly about
those problems there was no suppression
in the government ability to talk with
those to to to to address those um the
the uh the the the the uh appeals court
that looked at it agreed and in fact
what they did is they simplified the
ruling so that it only focused on legal
speech just as the Missouri versus Biden
did that so that the Biden
Administration couldn't go and tell them
to suppress my speech in the way they
actually did
um
second Kate has painted a picture of
voluntary suppression of expression as
if the Twitter is just next door and we
want to make sure that you only can talk
to your neighbors um this is a as Far
From Reality as you can imagine and if
you don't agree with me what I recommend
is you please go read the evidentiary
record in the Missouri versus Biden case
it is an absolutely shocking overreach
where the the the internet platforms
themselves are saying look this is this
is insane um now a lot of it you'll see
there's like this kind of Stockholm
syndrome they're shocked that this is
happening and they're like okay how can
we comply so that we can we can get out
from being uh the threats uh in fact in
Congressional hearings what was found uh
that the fa that Facebook was was really
so scared of in internal discussions
internal emails Facebook was scared of
the Biden administrations uh essentially
taking away basic regulatory Authority
in ways that would harm the company
destroy the company they complied this
was not a voluntary effort this was a
coerced effort by the Biden
Administration to suppress the uh
suppress speech um third uh this this
this this claim about Judge shopping is
amazing to me uh I mean that's a
standard claim that people make uh on
both the left and the right what I will
just say is that the judge himself is
was 98 to zero approved by the Senate
that that that the um that the three
judges on the fifth circuit approved it
and the and the fact that the Supreme
Court has granted to the case which is
something that only rarely due shows the
importance of the case and shows that
this is not simply judge shopping that
in fact this is an that that every judge
that has looked at this case has said
that is among the most important First
Amendment cases in the history of this
country uh just before I leave the judge
shopping attack I will just say that
this is a form of an ad hominum attack
right it's not actually a logical attack
on the ca on on the on the factual base
of the case or on the on the issues at
hand um uh uh Kate says that that Trump
did it too and I you know to I I agree
with that Trump did it too I am not a
political actor I care about public
health I care about about American free
speech rights I care about about science
and I think that the government should
have absolutely no role playing the kind
of policeman it did it started in the
Trump Administration and the bid
Administration expanded and they were
both wrong in doing it um uh K tries to
minimize the the kind of suppression
that I faced I'll tell you that as a
result of the kind of devastating
takedown induced by the uh by the by uh
by Francis Collins and Tony fouchy I was
a result of death I had I had death
threats against me I had attacks against
me it was a tremendously stressful time
in order to just do my basic job which
is to tell the public about scientific
results the way that I see them and
engage in scientific debates and I'll
tell you that every single one of my
colleagues who who were on the other
side of the the the um the B
Administration and the and the and the
co policies felt exactly the same way um
the uh there's a claim that I wasn't
that allowed to have my voice you know I
was put on a blacklist what that meant
was that only people who followed me
could hear my voice the purpose of the
platform if it was a neutral platform uh
would have been to let anyone hear my
voice the nor with the normal rules The
Blacklist was not I was not placed on
the black list because Twitter had some
policy to put jbari on a blacklist I was
placed on a blacklist because the
government asked Twitter to do
it um now as far as the the standing I I
my my standing in the case I just ask
you to read the evary record it wasn't
just one YouTube suppressed uh it was a
systematic effort by the government to
suppress scientific discussion on covid
and I have standing as do many many
other scientists that were suppressed uh
I'll just finish with the a last note
about whether we would have won the the
fight on lockdowns and school closures
what I the claim I made in my opening
statement was that there's pretty much
Universal acknowledgement that the
school closures were a tremendous
mistake even the New York Times has
admitted as much um I think that so and
that I think is absolutely true I say G
that that tremendous number of people
now agree that the lockdowns were a
mistake if you look at the Swedish
response to the pandemic which didn't
feature lockdowns there they have lower
all cause excess deaths than all of the
rest of Europe California has higher all
cax death that since the start of the
pandemic than Florida there's no good
evidence to say the lockdowns did much
of anything the the consensus on
lockdowns in is coming and it would have
been here much earlier had there been
free
expression um finally uh the the uh Kate
uh emphasizes this idea that that
there's a that that we're stepping
backwards in our ability for to have
governance and by governance what she
means I think is that some sort of uh
day taunt between governments and uh and
and these platforms so that the
platforms can set the rules that they
want for speech and they can be the
governments can be happy with them and
there's this like sort of happy
suppression with everyone's everyone's
happy with the suppression that's
happening uh that's how I read Kate's uh
Kate's characterization of it um in fact
this is an orwellian telling of the
actual factual record the actual factual
record does not show a voluntary uh
government is a speech with where the
the companies are competing with each
other in some in some Paradise to try to
like keep speech as open as possible
which the factual record shows is that
the government's work to suppress the
speech of regular people using the The
Leverage they had over the uh Financial
well-being of these Platforms in order
to suppress the speech of regular people
this is not simply just companies
fighting with sort of competing with
each other to find sort of a congenial
way I I'm completely in favor of
companies having an un uninter fered uh
capacity to say what kind of speech
belongs or does not belong on their
platforms that is not the contention in
the Missouri versus Biden case the
contention in the Missouri versus Biden
case is quite the opposite that the
Biden Administration and other
administrations should abide by the
First Amendment and that primarily is it
thank
[Applause]
you uh thank you to you both
uh we now go to the Q&A portion of the
evening and uh you're invited to uh line
up to ask uh whatever questions you'd
like uh also uh uh uh both Debaters uh
will be welcome to ask each other
questions whenever they would like uh
therefore my first question to either of
you uh Kate uh do you want to wait the
questions from the audience or would you
like to ask Jay a question uh Jay uh you
want to ask k a question okay uh they
wave the right at this point but you can
uh apply the right uh if you'd like to
as the Q&A proceeds I see a lot of uh
bright faces in front of the mics there
uh please ask your question as a
question I think I recognize you as
somebody I went to high school with um
um uh this is a question primarily for
Jay yeah um and uh basically I I think
it's very easy to agree with you that
the government ought not to interfere
when the government is supporting a
position that's wrong or when the
government is supporting a position
that's arguable but what about when the
government is
interfering with the expression with the
free expression of a falsehood that is
constitutionally protected let's say the
claim that uh covid vaccines have chips
in them that Bill Gates put in uh now
that's a false claim it's at least
arguably a harmful claim but it's a
constitutionally protected claim are you
against the government suggesting to
platforms that they probably shouldn't
give a lot of attention to that
claim I mean I think that the um the the
right so to answer your question I don't
think the government should suppress
that speech I think the government
should counter that speech and the way
the government counters that speech is
by building institutions within the
government that can trust in a
trustworthy way say no no there are no
chips in these vaccines by the way there
no chips in these vaccines
um the problem with the way the
government
behaved suppressing even true speech
even just regular scientific debate it
undermined the TR the public trust in
these institutions like the CDC like the
US surgeon general's office and as a
result the government lost the ability
to effectively counter misinformation
like that with more speech and I think
that's that's my I mean I think that's
the right thing if the if the government
is telling their the the honest truth as
best they know how and they build up
trust with the public as a result of it
there's not going to be a big problem
with misinformation PE people will say
wrong things all the time but that's not
that's not the problem the problem is
the inability to counter it with
trustworthy sources free speech allows
that the kind of suppression of speech
we had basically undermines the capacity
to deal with it uh Kate any comment from
you on the question I just want to point
out that you just said that the
government should build an institution
that can measure these types of things
and that is literally like kind of one
of the things that the CDC is in charge
of doing and so the fact that this is
something that kind of that the fact
that this was something that was
happening and the government was putting
this forward and also that one of the
recommendations in the giant record that
you make mention of in the in the
Missouri V Biden case was that a lot of
these requests were essentially that
they that Twitter didn't answer them by
T or Twitter or Facebook or whatever
didn't answer them by taking down speech
often they would put counter speech up
they would put they would allow like
something like the chips and vaccines
type of thing to go up and then they
would put like they would put a label on
it that said something effectively like
this has been disputed by so and so and
we're not sure if this is accurate
information and that was also called
censorship and so that is something that
I I think that like you just that what
you just said is something that you've
said the opposite for like and that
people who have supported and said that
these claims are censorship is not I
mean this can't all be censorship
everything that is like happening can't
all be censorship and it can't be having
speech and counter speech for the
government can't both be SP K they they
banned vaccine injured groups from
talking to each other at the request of
the government the the um the who's they
being the B Administration forc the
Facebook to do that forb absolutely in
the in the in the in the records of the
uh Missouri versus Biden case uh not not
only that I I'd say like the the way
that they in the ham-handed way they
forced the social media companies to tag
Mis like false information
misinformation actually I think spread
further distrust right so they put go
see what the CDC is saying on absolutely
true things so essentially saying look
this what what this regular Joe is
saying on online is wrong even if it was
it's just a link to a peer-reviewed
paper and they put it on uh on these on
these like you know vaccines are are are
microchipped I I think it was an ABS the
the way that the government regulated
speech online censored speech online
absolutely fueled the distrust of a
significant FR fraction of the public
about the vaccines it was an
absolute disaster for public health
communication but you just said the
counter speech was the way to solve the
problem of allowing First Amendment
protected speech that was wrong to stay
up I didn't say that this was counter
speech I'm saying that what they did was
sensoring I I'm saying that what they
that they if they wanted to build what
was censoring the labels that you say
are counter speech are now also
censorship no that what was what was no
I didn't say that you said that what I
said was that the bid administration's
demand to put the labels on was
censorship it was defamation of of
people's even when they were saying
correct things whether true or false
those labels went up
uh the the the Biden administration's
demands to put the counter speech isn't
I get to I get to be there as the
government right in front of you every
time you say something that's not
counter speech counter speech is uh that
you have a CDC that says we've done a
scientific study here's the here's the
thing and they buy they buy uh
advertising on the platform they have
public PSAs they there other mechanisms
other than intruding on how the social
media companies present and regulate the
speech that they have what what they did
was absolutely censorship they prevented
vaccine injured people from talking to
each other they forced Facebook to take
down speech of vaccine injured people
what do you think was going to happen to
them they're not going to start trusting
the government on
this Kate or you yeah all right well
next question yeah this question is for
Kate do you not see the failure of
threads Zuckerberg's no misinformation
version of Twitter that dropped from 100
million users to less than 10
and the broad almost Universal rejection
of Nina jenck and her thisinformation
governance board as a clear Democratic
repudiation of your
position I do I not see it as no I don't
see it as that I can you can you explain
a little bit more what you're what
you're asking me about yeah so like
you're saying that what threads as it
the fact that threads exist repudiates
my yeah the failure of threads which
promis to censor more than Twitter and
it's dropping from 100 million users on
the day on the first days of its release
to 10 now uh a couple months after its
release and the rejection of Nina jeno's
uh Global disinformation board the prise
to what Global disinformation board but
the Biden disinformation governance
board and I'm sure I mean Jay could
explain that to you further but uh the
clear rejection of that board because it
promised to censor and it prom promised
to intervene in the Democratic convers
that happens in
everyday people voted with their thumbs
essentially is what I'm saying they
moved they stayed on Twitter they did
not move to threads you not see that as
a repudiation of further censorship in
our
society no I don't see it as a
repudiation of further censorship I see
it as a market decision that people
decided that they didn't want to be on
threads I have not seen um I have seen
different numbers for the popularity of
threads um but there are lots of uh in
fact I've seen the threads is um growing
in popularity and that Twitter has
repeatedly um been losing both
advertisers and brand um brand
advertising and that it's been losing
users and so that seems to me to be uh
not a repudiation of uh the idea that
there are censorship but the fact that
um people are remaining on Instagram
that they're remaining on Facebook
they're remaining on other types of
platforms that are well governed and
that people are still all over the world
asking for these platform forms to be
better governed and better better um and
made safer and more responsive to their
concerns I think that I think that just
one example of uh of um supposedly
threads declining in users is not I mean
also like do you see like the collapse
of parlor and gab is a repudiation that
like that those were that claimed to be
non- censorship the fact that those
didn't have massive followings um those
don't seem the fact that they didn't
grow in massive popularity it doesn't
seem to be that people voted with their
thumbs and decided that they wanted to
go live in uncensored
environments a comment from you Jay on
the question of the answer I'll just say
like in terms of like the the the
popularity of platforms um how would we
know like how would you know given the
given the pervasive uh environment of
censorship uh we don't have a free
market in platforms and I'll say like
threads it absolutely is collapsed I
mean I tried to use it for a little a
while and I looked at it's like you it's
like you know it's Children of the Corn
you happy happy people talking to each
other um I mean I don't know maybe some
some people like
it uh EXC me please please let's keep it
orderly next question please yes this is
for both of you um I haven't heard much
discussion about the actual injunction
in the case which prevented um a broad
range of government agencies from
contacting social Med
platforms and I'm wondering what do you
think the upsides downsides of that the
injunction were was it too broad was it
perfectly tailored I thought that that
was exactly what I was talking about
that was that was the majority of what I
talked about was the fact that it was an
over Brad substantively over Brad
decision um that is that was that was
absolutely the issue in this case um and
it was over Brad and because it was so
over Brad it like it basically made it
so that there were all other areas of of
of Public Health or other types of
things or national security or terrorism
recruitment or child sexual abuse
material or other types of things the
the decision to to say like we'll keep
up legal speech and take down illegal
speech or criminal speech these are not
like binary choices someone has to
decide what falls into the category of
legal and illegal speech and that is
often decisions that like that the
government makes and then in tells the
tells the platforms to enforce and so
like these kinds of conversations it was
unclear how any of these were going to
take place in light of this decision
because it was so over Brad uh
commentary the government decided that
me saying to government DeSantis that
toddler masking made no sense was
illegal
speech right that's how that's how
YouTube decides to take down a video of
me talking to a sitting governor of
Florida uh if a government that that is
prohibited from doing that by the
Missouri V Biden case that is a win for
free speech it's not a subtle win it's a
real actual actual win the government
abused this ambiguity that Kate is
talking about in order to suppress your
speech do we really want
that next question this is a kind of
two-part question about disinformation
addressed to both of you uh Dr bia's
case involved making a great deal out of
a specific example while what's at issue
is a general principle and you know what
bridged those which what bridged the
bridged the Gap in Dr V's argument was
suggestions about public trust and so on
good to hear in some more detail how one
gets from the general specific claims
about covid to General issues about
censorship because you know you can have
other explanation for what went wrong
you know those damn Democrats is always
a thing people go for right um yes so so
um how do you how do you how do you
bridge the gap there between the
specific case to the general principle
in the Missouri Biden case I mean I I
think I just just to answer specifically
your like directly your question I think
that public trust is a is a subtle thing
and it's and the censorship is a brutal
way to deal with a very subtle thing
public trust and public health comes
from telling the truth saying when
you're wrong you're that you're wrong uh
not coercing the public trusting the
public as much as you expect the public
to trust you that's that's I mean this
is my expertise that's what what I'd say
in in other areas I would say as a
citizen if I'm if I'm feeling that the
government is censoring me I'm not going
to trust the person that's censoring I
have this like in
American disgust for people telling me
not to say something I want to say it or
telling me not to read something I want
to read it uh it seems counterproductive
to go go down the direction we've gone
if we want to build public trust and I
think that I but I think I share your
desire to have it built I just think
that this this is the wrong way to do it
comment uh k no uh next
question hi so I have two questions one
really short for Kate one really short
for Jay first uh Kate I have a question
related to um coercion so um would you
not agree that restriction is different
from complete outright Banning in the
context that there is coercion from the
government to social media platforms and
then for Jay as well I have a question
uh you mentioned that you don't have
political biases in terms of who you I
have political biases I just don't care
that much in legal in legal terms when
you present a case you don't have that
bias supposedly right so I have a
question which is um you spoke um
vehemently against out against lockdowns
so why didn't you present the case
against the Trump Administration when
there was a almost a full year of
national lockdowns in that context I I
permitted the young man two questions I
really shouldn't have but uh because you
only get one but anyway uh Kate uh the
question what has to do with what
coercion did you follow the question not
really but I I think you you asked what
the difference was between restriction
and
coercion yeah like you kind of
insinuated throughout the debate that um
there was a kind of big censorship uh in
that regard but would you not agree that
there's more um that this was more kind
of a restriction of the Biden
administration's ability to communicate
with social media Platforms in some
regards rather than a complete outright
ban to the B Biden Administration to
communicate with those platforms oh okay
in the final preliminary injunction the
ruling okay so the so the the term the
coercion that is being talked about the
question of coercion comes up in the
context of whether or not um the
government was coercive to a sufficient
degree as to count for censorship for
the purposes of Bantam Books in the
First Amendment this is the idea that
essentially by requesting of Twitter
that they take something done they
weren't requesting they were actually
threatening this was like the the the
the idea that like it would be a shame
if something happened to your to your
you know your nice business that you run
here type of idea that this is like a
threat or um a threat of Regulation that
is where the concept of coion comes in
so I just kind of want to set that aside
the um the decision that came out of the
um of D's opinion um in on July 4th was
essentially a question of restriction of
um it was it was very clear that it was
a complete restriction and that these
were undefined terms which is what we
like which is what we mean by over Brad
it was unclear which government
officials it was going to apply to it
seemed to apply to all government
officials and it was unclear what type
of behavior and what types of areas and
what types of speech from as I said
National Security to child sexual abuse
material and criminal and and other
types of things to things like covid and
misinformation and so no I don't think
that it was um I I think that because it
could be so widely construed as to be a
ban then people out of an abundant
government officials out of abundance of
caution would restrict all would would
decline to engage with platforms at all
because they believed that this decision
had forbidden them from doing so um Jay
um ignore the question about Trump and
just address that first question because
there's only one question so address the
first question okay answer please uh so
so yeah just real fast Kate just
mischaracterized the the Dy decision the
Dy decision explicitly names agencies it
names the sisa which is part of the
state department it names the surgeon
general's office it names the CDC it
names the ni AG it names it names
explicit government agencies that are
covered by the by the ruling and it
names specific actions by those agencies
what of when it can is is enjoined
against telling these companies who and
what to censor uh so it's I mean that's
just decision no that was actually Dow's
decision has it lists exactly the names
of those agencies yeah and then that was
restricted further and further defined
point you said it they they just it was
a general government decision that's not
not just not true um on on just very
very fast on Trump uh I did I in 2020 I
was I was a you know a scientist I
didn't know anything about media I
didn't know I'd never written an oped
before um I spoke up against lockdowns
the best I could I did I did TV
interviews I I did science to to to show
to to ask whether lockdowns were
necessary and and you concluded that it
wasn't based on the scientific work I
did a lot of my advocacy in 2020 later
in 2021 came from the scientific work
not the other way around uh next
question
yes this question is primarily for Dr
vachara um when it comes to this case
what do you see as the ideal Free Speech
outcome is it just kind of an
acknowledgement that you and your
co-plaintiffs were wronged an awarding
of Damages or I think you know maybe
there's there's something coming perhaps
from the political right a little more
about uh regulating these platforms as
public utilities and mandating a little
more speech from all sides what what's
your view on where you want that to go I
mean I'm actually fairly agnostic about
any of these regulations I I think that
they're fine and legitimate as long as
they don't violate the First Amendment
what I what I really want is for the
government to just stop violating the
First Amendment especially in areas of
Science and public health I think it's a
tremendous disaster when it does that at
all but especially in these areas it
hurts it hurts the poor it hurts the
vulnerable it hurts the working class it
hurts children ways that are tangible
and I just want them to stop I I think
pres Biden essentially sends a signal
government agencies that were far out of
line to to just stop doing it that
that's why I've been doing it I'm not
expecting any monetary Awards I'm not
certainly not expecting apology from the
bid Administration they're still going
to Supreme Court saying that they were
right to censor so you know I just want
them to
stop uh Kate any comment question no uh
next
question um hi my question is for Kate
um in your opening statement and and
even throughout the debate you
insinuated that you believe there is
some you know you know positive reason
why the government should be suppressing
or censoring dis and misinformation is
that your
position that I that there were positive
reasons or that you believe that it is a
just cause to censor disinformation and
misinformation no I don't think that I
insinuated that at any point I was not
trying to State at any point that I
thought that the government should be
censoring anything I think that my
argument was essentially that the
government has conversations with
private platform forms and that those
sometimes like those sometimes result in
the in platforms which have their own
First Amendment rights deciding
something to do and has nothing to do
with I don't think that it's a just
cause you mentioned that there were
certain safety considerations that could
stem from disinformation
spreading I do you believe that that
that I guess my question is do you
believe the government is a source of
Truth and should be considered a source
of
Truth uh you're Bing the witness yeah
thank
you you want to respond to do I believe
the government is a source of Truth the
government says something okay EXC
excuse me just a moment let's get back
to the procedure here uh Kate do you
want to say anything further Jade do you
want to defend Kate on this
issue please I mean just okay just to
you know to Steel Man case argument I
think what she's saying is that she she
thinks that the that the the the um that
the the the private entities like the
like Twitter like Facebook ought to have
a lot of rain and and the way that they
get that rain is by having rules that
the government sets correctly neutrally
and that that the Missouri versus Biden
case harms the ability for the
government to set neut know neutral
rules or correct rules that allow this
space to open uh that's where the
disagreement really fundamentally is I
don't think that Kate you were saying
that you wanted the government to have
the truth right but okay oh yes no I
mean
please unfortunately we got to limit the
rights of you questioners because we got
a lot of other people but I think both
of them are coming to the party young
lady so You' be able to talk to her then
uh yeah um I have a multi-part question
but I'll be very succinct um the first
the first part of please only one
question even only one question please
um okay so I think the the premise of
the first amendment is that even a small
Act of government government sensor took
SL sure so the premise of the first
amendment is that even a small Act of
government censorship can lead to far
greater censorship um because of the
because the power of the government is
so great in this context so Kate's point
that the censorship that Professor
bataria experienced on Twitter is not
really censorship is not convincing to
me at all in part because the social
media's design decisions and
architecture decisions have been
iteratively changed over and over again
since 2014 and even before in response
to misinformation I'm getting there um
and what's your question so my question
is um if the law is supposed to create
Universal principles over time that
carry forth isn't the small experience
of censorship that Professor bataria is
claiming to have experienced dangerous
in the sense that the social media
companies have this power to iteratively
alter the designs over time in response
to these
demands I I'm I'm not convinced at all
of Kate's sort of suggestion that it's
not really really censorship and second
part is EXC that's Smith stop thank you
Kate would you like to respond to that
did you no I'm okay what I'm okay yeah
you pass on I like I think it's just as
important to sometimes decide when not
to speak as when to speak yeah can can I
can just on that point I think it's
actually quite important point because
some of the demands by the third parties
that the government essentially
deputized to do to enact the censorship
were demands on social media platforms
to change their terms of service to make
make previously acceptable speech no
longer acceptable so the government is
not just simply that they're asking
giving the platforms a list of people
and ideas to censor they're changing the
they're forcing the platforms to change
their rules to comply in ways so that
they that further government censorship
could could be said to just oh just it's
just voluntary it's a very very
Insidious thing that the government did
here um and uh you know just it's just
it was just wrong it's a it's it's such
a clear violation of the of the First
Amendment it's not just a question of
the go of the social media companies
having to get to to set the rules they
want it was really the government
suppressing speech in this in the in a
very 21st century way uh next
question uh so I think that maybe the
issue is not even government cens
censorship but perhaps it goes further
that these social media companies are
run by people who subscribe to this
Orthodoxy of thought within Silicon
Valley so how do we deal with the fact
that these social media companies have a
tendency proclivity to censor on behalf
of one political ideology as opposed to
the other one in terms of free speech
and protecting it I this was really what
I was trying to drive home with the the
bulk of my remarks and I somehow I'm
getting kind of like painted in this way
that I think that I'm prover censorship
government CDC these agencies they are
one part of a pluralistic voice that
should be speaking on behalf of like
users generally and this is a
conversation that should not just be
made by King makers that happen to own
million like user Platforms in Silicon
Valley I believe that these are that
this is a that that we are moving
towards a more kind of progressive idea
of a government or governance like
structure that is going to be that can
give feedback into how these policies
are created and that it's not just
someone like Elon Musk making a decision
or Mark Zuckerberg making a decision or
the people that work for him and that
there these are multi-stake
multi-stakeholder and pluralistic
decisions to be made comment J
I mean we've we've had the same
conversation over so yeah okay uh next
question hi I just want to premise this
by um a physician who was censored and
signed the great barington declaration
and thank you um I think a lot of lost
when we talk about this when we realize
the consequence of the censorship in the
medical sector the consequence is that
we had a breach in standard of care as
it relates to informed consent
because Physicians were afraid to
disclose the risk and benefits as
related to the covid vaccine biologics
mass m mandates and the like and my
question is I'd like Jay to expand as a
fellow physician on the consequence of
this censorship and the failure to
provide informed consent in the medical
sector because this is a big Point
that's missed often I mean thank first
thank you for signing the great thank
you for that
question I mean I I don't know what to
say other than amen I mean like that
that uh that uh the the uh in California
there was a law called AB 2098 that
basically said to Physicians that if you
don't comply tell your patients what the
CDC is telling say to tell your patients
you could lose your license I have no
idea how patients who are treated by
physicians who are governed by such a
law can be said to have had informed
consent they're not getting the honest
opinion of the Physicians and that is
then it wasn't just in California that
Physicians felt this the censorship
effort undermined medicine it undermined
public health and it and it led to the
damaging results that we saw have seen
to the school kids around the country uh
as a result of of of the censorship we
really paid an enormous cost it's not
simply just a theoretical thing where
like you know my abstract rights were
violated that I think that's that's bad
I don't like that but like but that's
what's worse what's worse is that
regular people pay the price of this I
mean we have a responsibility to tell I
have I felt the responsibility to tell
you all what I thought sometimes I'm
wrong sometimes I'm right but I had that
responsibility and and doctors also had
that responsibility and it was taken
away from them by these actions
absolutely thank you Kate no no no uh
guys uh we're running uh out of time and
so the uh only recourse now is for you
to ask a question and then uh the
speakers might address it in their
summation uh but just ask your question
and then the next question as the
question as well okay then I will be
brief with the only pretense that I'd
like to thank all of you or both of you
for um for this discussion I'm big fans
of both of yours and we can't have good
faith discussions about this there's no
hope uh wondering what you both are
thinking about um you know whether or
not the kind of democratic and epistemic
priors are in place um if we are in a
position to get to the kind of
collaborative pluralistic governance
regime over um the public sphere that
Kate you seem optimistic about out um
and that could be with regards to
government uh agency and kind of you
know technocratic ability to get it
truth or the public ability to kind of
filter out misinformation and actually
arrive at some kind of thank you for
your question and the next question
please they they'll file it away
possibly the summations go ahead my
question is um can you be both against
the censorship of Dr J and still at the
same time believe that the injection
deprives the government of super
important policymaking tools such as how
could they address the impact of social
media on um theage girl mental health
while they complying with this ruling us
what the question again was what can you
be bought against the government's
censorship of Dr J but still at the same
time believe that the injunction
deprives the government of a pretty
important policymaking tool under this
ruling how could they address the
problem for example social media impact
on um the nature show of mental health
okay yesk uh next
question thank you so my question is on
Section um 230 of the communication
decency act wow which states that no
provider or user of an interactive
Computer Service should be treated as a
publisher um there's been a lot of
controversy because obviously that um
ruling and law came out decades before
social media came into play today social
media considers themselves as a
distributor not as a publisher obviously
if they're considered a publisher
they're then liable and so the question
for both of you is should they be
treated as a distributor or a publisher
and if you think they're a distributor
what other alternative Avenues um should
there be and from a legislative
standpoint to ensure that social media
is uh and free speech is regulated great
next question yeah hi my P my question
is for Professor clonic uh so I think at
the beginning you acknowledge some of
these messages that were sent to the
companies were quote questionable um but
I don't know exactly where you would
draw the line between job owning and
coercion and I'm just wondering if you
would be willing to agree that perhaps
some instances of what the government
did did cross that line even if you also
think that the remedy was overb okay
next question
okay real quick followup on the uh
gentleman's question on Section 230
there were numerous instances of public
officials basically uh saying that they
would revisit section 230 protection for
these uh social media companies do you
think that that constituted coersion um
and uh F do we have we have a final oh
that's it yeah well uh thank you for
those questions it looks like we'll have
a lot to talk about at the Afterparty
and um both of these people as you can
see are very approachable and uh we're
going to draft them both to come to the
Afterparty but now uh they each get five
minutes of summation and uh the
affirmative goes first so take it away
Kate would you like to take the podium I
know I'll just I'll just sit um so this
so to the section 230 which is not
really relevant in this exact debate
because it is not this is a First
Amendment case not a section 230 case I
will just briefly say that section 230
um
accepts intermedi platform
intermediaries um from from torous
liability um if they host speech for the
purposes of of defamation and other
types of speech TS um I I don't think
that that is um I I I think that I'm
glad I don't I think it was the last
person who just said that there have
been that Trump famously issued an
executive order that threatened that
specifically said that it was going to
remove section 230 intermediary
liability after they believed that the
that the platforms were censoring him
and so like I don't know of a more
clear-cut case of actually making good
on a threat that he had made over and
over again um to hurt the companies uh
than when he issued used his power as
president to issue an executive order in
which he punished the companies and took
away um threatened to take tried to take
away their um their uh intermediary Li
liability immunity um that being said I
want to just I want to say that I said
at the outset in the course in my
remarks that I do think that there were
a number of instances in which there
were there was problematic um things
that the government said to the
companies I I'm I completely disagree
with how the government reached out to
the companies I think that this is a
problem my problem with this decision
was that it was over Brad and that it
basically cast the um it gave very
little instruction to we should set up
national internet policy or how the
actual organic policy of the internet as
it has been constructed over the last 25
years has developed and I that is that
is I think that that is a very middle of
kind of the road reasonable decision to
to say I'm not talking about the
government being um the Arbiters of
truth I am not talking about them
deciding what is true and what is not
true I am simply saying that these are
decisions in which uh the government
specifically cannot be I am
acknowledging this the government cannot
be the one making internet policy I am I
think that there is a really Pro there
is a huge problem and like this is 1997
we decided this in Reno versus ACLU in
which we specifically said that the
communications decency Act was
unconstitutional under the first
amendment that the government cannot
make these rules that are going to
dictate what is on these platforms and
that we're going you know and that they
can't decide that it's indecent to have
pornography which is first amendment
protected speech and this is this is
we've established that over and over
again and so we have come to this middle
ground in which private platforms which
have their own First Amendment rights
have a right to construct and to create
basically a curated space as they want
to curate it should the government have
much say not a lot but some say in that
in a multi-stakeholder society and a
pluralistic Western democracy yes I
think that there is some role in which
that has a place to play after all
someone elects these officials and so
there are there is like there is
absolutely um a a place for this to have
go forward and having a over Brad
decision is just going to risk having um
having absolutely no type of Regulation
and make the public health discussion
worse thank you uh would you uh thank
you Kate uh you have five minutes would
you like to take the
podium I'll just you'll do it from the
chair take take the podium uh so so uh
I'll just note uh the the Kate's uh
response about section 230 highlights
the importance of the Missouri versus
Biden case if Missouri versus Biden was
in force the preliminary injunction was
in forc during the Trump Administration
that executive order would have been
unconstitutional under the preserv Biden
case or or or legal or I'm not sure what
the right legal term is I'm only a
fringe epidemiologist
um so the the the key the key point is
the government should not be using have
the ability to use threats against these
companies to coers it to give it to to
only allow the kinds of speech that it
that the government wants on there and
the Missouri Biden case is not over Brad
it it specifically addresses that key
point it it it lists specific agencies
that over overreached about this and
says those agencies are not allowed to
do this it gives a set of of of uh and
especially you know as as we've seen as
it's gone up the courts the the the uh
you know up the appeals process they
haven't really fundamentally restricted
the the the scope of it they what
they've the the the the the the scope of
like what the government is or is not
allowed to do regarding telling social
media companies what and who to censor
every single Court that's looked at this
is agreed that they're not they
shouldn't be what they oversteep the
bounds they shouldn't be doing this the
what's at issue right now is whether the
government is should be allowed to go
tell give give grants to Stanford
University and say Stanford you guys
figure out who ought to be censored and
then use Stanford as an intermediary to
go censor censor everybody that's what's
currently an issue that's what the
that's the difference that's the main
difference between what the appeals
court did and what the what the dowy uh
Judge Terry Dy did in the in the in the
Circuit Court um or in the in the in the
lower court so you have a you have what
you have is not an over Brad decision
what you have is a decision that is is
absolutely tailor made to address the
key problem of free speech that happened
under two administrations during the
pandemic and that we that still the
government is still telling uh the
courts that it needs that power to
censor you and me in order to protect
the public and so I'm just going to end
with saying that that is a lie it is an
absolute lie that is and you can tell it
was a lie because they Ed the power to
censor free discussion of P absolutely
key important public health and
scientific matters that had been had
they been freely debated would have
resulted in a vastly different and
better policy much more akin to what
happened in Sweden than than what
happened in the United States and uh and
as a result our school children would be
better educated many people who are
currently dead would be alive and the
Public Health Trust would not be in the
in the in uh would be would not be
destroyed the way it has been censorship
kills and the Missouri versus Biden case
is a is a absolutely key uh decision
that if it's upheld will prevent this
kind of overreach by governments uh in
the future and I and and you know I I
I'm I'm keeping my fingers crossed my I
I don't want to like put my entire faith
in the American uh system of governments
on based on one decision uh especially
since I mean I love this country um but
my God if we lose the reservation Biden
case I don't know what Free Speech looks
like in this country thank
you okay
um Grant please open the voting for the
final vote uh to my embarrassment in our
Sunday confusion I left the so for
Tootsie Roll at home but uh but the
Afterparty will be held at my home and
the winner will be awarded the tootsie
role uh after at the Afterparty uh so
again the resolution reads the making of
national enget policy was hindered
rather than helped by the July 4th
Federal Court ruling that restricted the
Biden administrations Communications
with social media platforms please vote
yes no or undecided at the res about the
resolution again our party is two blocks
up town follow me follow the crowds uh
and you can join both Debaters food and
drink uh available to all uh on uh we we
are not done at the so Forum we host
debates every month and uh our next
debate will be Monday January 29th and
there the resolution will read
government must play a role in fostering
scientific and technological progress by
funding basic research you wouldn't
imagine uh that that could be debated
but Libertarians do regard it as
debatable uh the affirmative will be
taken by Tony Mills uh of the American
Enterprise Institute the negative will
be taken by Terence Terrence key author
of a book called the economic law
of scientific research all of these uh
debates uh that I'm going to about to
read to you are available uh for ticket
sales on our website the soul forum.org
on Monday February
26 uh uh we're going to have a
resolution that will read the root cause
of the Israeli Palestinian conflict is
the Palestinians rejection of is
Israel's right to exist uh now that
debate will uh be held not here but at
the Soho playhouse on vanam Street about
a mile uh to the west of here U but
tickets are available the resolution uh
will be defended by American journalist
Eli Lake and opposed by uh journalist uh
Jeremy Hammond again that will be at the
so Playhouse uh uh about a mile uh west
of here uh uh on March on Monday March
25th we're going to return to a covid
pandemic issue and that resolution will
read capitalism has been a key factor in
leaving the United States unprepared to
address the
covid-19 pandemic uh that will be
defended by best-selling author Joon
asera co-author
of the big fail what the pandemic
revealed about who America protects and
who it leaves behind in that case taking
the negative will be me uh uh uh and uh
Grant how we doing on the voting uh do I
see you anywhere Grant what uh you're uh
the votes are still rolling in pretty
much there pretty so was it two minutes
one more minute okay fine uh and then uh
we are going to have in April yet
another uh aspect of the covid issue uh
uh the uh the the uh debate uh will be
uh uh based on the resolution government
imposed restrictions during the co
pandemic were prudent and essential and
that will be opposed by Tom Woods of of
the Tom Woods podcast and defended by
Brent Orel of the American Enterprise
Institute drum roll please uh because
I'm about to read uh the uh the uh
results uh uh the uh again the
resolution the making of internet policy
was hindered rather than helped the yes
votes Grew From
99.6% to
18.1% and picked up
8.5% of the vote congratulations to the
S side but the 8.5 was the number to
beat the negative went from
41.5 to
73.4 so uh it picked up
31.9% so Jay uh you must come over and
accept your tootsie role congratulations
to you
both
[Applause]
e